so I'm going to talk about the readable
code today code that's hard to read
causes the who the heck wrote this
moments now they're probably all of you
have experienced that and that code is
error-prone it's intimidating people
that have to work with code that's hard
to read they they tend to really not
they're afraid to refactor it they work
around and they put band-aid fixes on it
without really understanding it which
increases technical debt and it's taxing
as far as the time it takes to
understand that code every time so we
should all try to write more readable
code and our goal here should be to
write code that minimizes the time it
takes someone to understand it and the
important note here that someone might
be you in six months
like how many of you have have had this
hood hack wrote this moment and then
realized oh that was me a few months ago
so today I'm gonna talk obviously this
is a giant topic I'm gonna talk just
about a collection of things that are my
pet peeves that I see a lot in the
codebase it's gonna be not as much code
architecture in general but things like
naming formatting when do you come and
do you need to comment code there's
there's a big debate about that so let's
start now formatting all of you I'm sure
have written code here so I'm not going
to talk about basic things like well you
gotta indent your code you got to be
consistent in whitespace but two things
that I would like to stress is one you
do have to have a style guide you need
to document it somewhere put in your
company wiki and stick to it so whatever
your preferences are you gotta be
consistent everybody in your company has
to be on board with it and the second
thing that just kills me a lot is line
length you do need to have a sane limit
for line length now back in the old day
people used to use terminals like that
and all software companies enforced the
80 character line limit because those
CRT screens would be 80 by 25 characters
you couldn't fit more and so you had to
that that was a hard limit 80 characters
per line or it would be just hard to
read the code but now we have giant
screens you know maybe five years from
now everybody will be developing on
screens that are as big as as big as
this projector screen so does that mean
we don't have to care about line lengths
anymore well you have a giant screen
that's great well how about you fit
multiple files in it I often like having
a two or even three column view in my
text editor working on several files at
the same time in the front-end world
it's often your JavaScript and CSS or
JavaScript and a template so it's having
a big screen is not really a good excuse
for having super long lines or you know
sometimes you might be on the laptop
screen maybe you're on the go maybe you
just decided to take a break and sit on
the couch you don't have your big screen
on and of course you work on a team
maybe you have a giant screen but you're
your buddy reviewing your code is on a
laptop and lastly well long lines are
just hard to read even even if you do
have a big screen like there's a giant
screen right there in the hallway don't
make lines that are as long as that guy
there's just hard to read you know we
would with the way we read text we are I
likes moving top to bottom and a little
bit left to right when there's too much
left to right it becomes uncomfortable
and in typography they have this concept
the advice that you should generally
have 45 to 19 characters per line which
really aligns with this old-fashioned
standard of 80 characters per line well
we do have bigger screens now maybe we
can bump it up to 100 120 840 lines but
I wouldn't really go more than 140
characters per line that's just too long
so don't make lines like this like don't
make your coworker scroll every time
they need to figure out what's going on
in the function and
again this this might be bug prone
because you don't know what's at the end
and you might skip it so you do format
your code you have shorter line so you
have a bunch of parameters in a function
split them up to be one for each line
next thing a big topic commenting many
people are convinced that you should
write code that doesn't require comments
and I generally agree with that
I think our goal our eye our ideals
should be your code should not need
comments because comments often get out
of date or often we comment code that
just really needs to be refactored and
instead of refactoring the code we just
add a comment explaining how complicated
it works or why it's so ugly of course
in real life we sometimes you have to
put comments in code but I do think that
comments in general gravitate toward
code that's questionable for example
what does this function do if you have
just five seconds to look at that code
you immediately see what it does maybe
do if you've done a lot of run that work
me but it it's not immediately obvious
right this this snippet of code does the
implements the infinite scrolling when
you scroll to the bottom of the page we
maybe load more content more pictures or
more news so you could be moderated to
just add a comment say oh this is
infinite scrolling so you kind of show
that this this block of code is a
transpose for infinite scrolling but it
would be even better is hey what if we
assign this function this callback
function to a variable called infinite
scroll handler you know and that way we
don't need the comment it sits in the
variable name so look out for things
like that and when you when you're
tempted to write a comment think can I
change the code to be more obvious
there's often comments like that that
don't really add knowledge generally if
the code is straightforward you there's
no sense of repeating that in the
comment
maybe when you're initially developing
that code you had your thought process
and you put about your comments I'm
gonna do this here I'm gonna do that
here and then you actually fill those
blanks with code but your comments like
that are unnecessary and often
misleading because you might change the
code and not change the comment
sometimes we do so this is an example of
when we have to add a comment so I was
doing some front-end work and I needed
to change the style of an input
placeholder and you can do it with
modern browsers using selectors like
that but turns out you cannot group
these selectors you know you cannot turn
it to one selector and just use comma to
separate these selectors for different
browsers turns out you can't do that at
least Chrome and Firefox would not read
that so this is an example of where you
do want to put a comment because maybe
your coworker will be using that code
and hilling oh that waterway for space
I'm gonna combine all these selectors
and then he would break the view so
unfortunately in the real world there
there is a place for comments like that
but another thing that I like to think
about if I have a comment explaining
what's happening or what's gonna happen
if the code is relatively complicated
maybe I should consider turning it into
the log statement so I have this comment
so the main policy found we're gonna add
the user to an existing account you
might you might win in two places if you
turn that into a log statement you know
that way we still explain what the code
does to the reader and we add some
useful logging so often comments should
really change into log statements
another big topic naming things
everybody's favorite right there there
are holy wars on that every other day
now in my practice I found that there
are some words that are just always
ambiguous or almost always
let's look at that code what do you
think it does team user provisionary
process login does somebody want to take
a stab at it what do you think this
method does it processes login right
clear as mud
well turns out that this this method
does a lot of things and this is a real
example from our code base it's a sort
of a post registration action that when
you're creating a user we want to make
sure that we put them on the right
account we set the right metadata on
their account and maybe we set some
cookies so it does a lot of things and I
guess the person writing that piece of
code did not could not think of a more
concrete way of naming this method
because it does a lot of things and so
they call it process so watch out for
these words if you if you're tempted to
use a word like that in your variable or
method name think twice these are almost
always ambiguous and do not really
communicate what what your method does
so I took some time to think about the
alternatives so validate form is a
really big offender you I see this a lot
in the code different peoples code
people would say validate form or check
form that doesn't really communicate
what's the outcome of this operation are
we validating the form and submitting it
or are we just returning some errors are
we returning some errors in an array or
are we just alerting the user in the GUI
that they have errors in the form so try
at more specific examples of a method
that does some sort of form validation
would be get errors you know when you
look at this method it's super clear
that method will return me probably an
array or a map of errors or if I if I
just want to know if my form is valid
well just have a method that's is valid
and you know that it returns true or
false there's no ambiguity here
or in some web frameworks the way you
process a form you call something like
bind from request and then it may take
two callbacks a callback if the form is
valid and then a callback if the form is
invalid getters and setters are another
big big area where it's it may not be
obvious what your your get get method
does for example get token right
authentication token where do we get
this token maybe it's a method on a user
object on your server side or a special
education object so it's not it's not a
mistake that I have get token on both
left and right columns now if I have a
user object and that user object already
has a token field on it that somehow got
there and all I want to do is retrieve
that value get token is probably totally
fine I think the general convention is
that your get and set methods should be
just simple your get method should be
simple lightweight accessors for the
data that's already there just like user
gift name or user not get email however
if we're if we're trying to retrieve
information from an external source
you know there's potentially a costly
operation yet is really not a good idea
you really want to communicate that
we're gonna download data from read it
from a database or download it from an
another server so something like fetch
would be a better name or if we're
generating a token again it could be a
computationally intensive operation
let's communicate that let's say
generate token or create token so
consider using names like that another
example of course this is specific
because it's hard to talk about these
names in general in each application you
would have your specific business logic
and that's precisely why it's not a good
idea to just say check or process or
validate
for example we have this method called
check restricted plugins and we have a
diagram editor and it loads and then
some plugins are restricted you have to
have a pro subscription to use them so
check restricted restricted plugins
again does not communicate what happens
when we check turns out that what this
method in the codebase actually did is
it alerted the user saying hey you need
a Pro subscription to to use this
plug-in that you're trying to use so
really a better name for that method
would have been something like alert if
restricted plugins or alert about
restricted plugins and finally the the
process login example that I used before
a better name for that would have been
something like run post registration
actions and yes this is generic but the
reason that what why we would want to
even create this method with such a name
is if we want to use it in multiple
places and they would be specific to how
we in our product run post registration
actions but it's still more it still
communicates more than just process
login you're not even sure if process
login is about logging in or registering
a new user turns out that it's actually
about registration so do you think about
things like that use a dictionary user
co-worker I think an extra five or ten
minutes you spend coming up with a
better name will go a long way in in the
future will reduce that maintenance that
extra technical depth that a confusing
name would have also another good rule
of thumb if you can't come up with a
verb your method is probably doing too
much and you need to split it up in
several methods may sound obvious but
there's numerous examples of functions
that are overloaded because they were
named something like check or process or
make and people thought well what I'm
doing really fits this method so instead
of making a new method I'm gonna add
another thing that this check or process
routine will does I'm processing data
right programming is all about
processing data
in a way and here's a quote that I like
from a github page idiomatic jas that
contains just good practices about
writing consistent idiomatic code all
code base should look like a single
person wrote it no matter how big the
project is no matter how many people
contributed to that whether you're a 5
person or 500 or 5,000 people
organization so in some cases you would
have conventions different frameworks
would use different verbs in a certain
way all this check and validate and
other things so you may have a lingo
that you use in your organization and
everybody understands what that is the
consistency does matter so using boolean
SCI I think this deserves a separate
topic specifically naming them here's
another what does this do
snippet so what do you think does this
method you show onedrive import anyone
wants to take a guess yeah so something
about what Microsoft onedrive what do
you think this method does in the
product show onedrive input input sure
what files imported
you know or maybe show a dialog for the
import right well turns out that in our
code this is again example from our code
base turns out that this method really
returns a boolean that says whether we
should show the import dialog or know
again that once you see the code it's
it's kind of obvious but it's not
obvious to the user of a method it's not
obvious if you read a place where this
method is called so this brings me to an
important point when you have a variable
or a function that returns a boolean
make it crystal clear that this function
or this value holds a boolean it can
only be true or false it doesn't do
anything else that doesn't have side
effects
it returns true or false so good
examples like this are should show what
one dr import that would have been
clearer so use prefixes like is has can
that makes it super clear that this is a
boolean that this doesn't actually show
a dialog or toggle something it just
gives you true or false so another thing
who heard about the boolean trap and
here's an example of it and i hey this
is it i'm gonna have more example like
this what does this code you well we
from the name we kind of we can guess
that oh it probably returns an SVG for
for a page in a document but what are
these true and false parameters are the
first parameter i can kind of guess DPI
that makes sense we need to if you
export to SVG you need DPI for images
but i have no idea what these true and
false parameters are and i have to look
up the definition and and takes takes
extra time to do that and i might mess
it up easily sometimes there are methods
that have five boolean parameters in
different orders and it's just true
false true false it's it's unmanageable
so certain languages have named
parameters javascript doesn't but you
have objects so one way of de
obfuscating that and i strongly
encourage you to do that is by passing
an object to your function that that
takes billions especially if you have a
method that takes more than say four
arguments you should consider using an
object anyway because it just gets
unwieldy
you have a long line you have to
remember what what to pass and in what
order objects really are better for this
and they they do have a couple of
downsides like it is it's harder to
process you pass an object and you need
to then retrieve values from an object
or if you're trying to enforce type
safety through google closure compiler
or typescript something like that you
you do need to
it's harder to you need to define a
special type for the object so another
alternative for that if if you can't
pass an object or you're not willing to
or in the language that you use there's
really no convention to pass object
parameters to a function you could still
pass your arguments but at least
annotate them like that one per line and
add a comment this pattern has been used
a lot in the C++ world and other
languages it's nothing new but consider
doing that lastly don't try to play code
golf your goal is not to write implement
your your logic in as few number of
lines or characters as possible we're
not playing that game where it's all
about the readability so anything I just
want to talk about how we can get better
at writing readable code obviously I
just scratch the surface
give you a list of my favorite things to
to rant about but here's this book that
I found out that I started meeting it's
got pretty good advice I use some of the
ideas from that book and this
presentation is called the art of
readable code you can buy it on the rila
or Amazon and there's even the free
online version another way you can
actually practice it don't be shy and
asking for feedback in code reviews and
I hope that you all do code reviews and
your team and it goes both ways if you
are unsure about a good name leave a
comment on your pool request
soliciting feedback hey I really I'm
really not sure about this method can
you suggest a better name and then as a
reviewer I don't think it's nitpicking I
think it's important to suggest better
names if you feel like that name is
really confusing it and it's ambiguous
and another website that I really like
is exorcism IO
anybody heard of it Oh awesome so the
idea of this website is you you have a
series of programming exercises they're
relatively simple and you can use it
just to learn a language but another way
you can use it is you implement a simple
programming exercise maybe writing a
string for a hundred times and writing
different strings but you can
try to implement something simple but in
a very clear structure than idiomatic
way using whatever your favorite design
principles are object-oriented
functional and then you submit that code
and you get feedback they call it
nitpicking from from other users and
because the whole purpose of this
exercise is to write clear idiomatic
code it's a it's a good way to practice
this on a small scale lastly here's some
more resources that I have in my
presentation in pneumatic GS that I
mentioned must read for all JavaScript
developers a few other useful articles I
already posted the presentation on
github so here's a link to it follow me
on Twitter check out lucid at go listen
Co if you're interested about our
company were always hiring we're
starting our recruiting season now and
thanks
[Applause]